We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David p here is once again a color absolutely
destroying me on something that I actually
never said and does not even align with my
political ideology.
What am I talking about?
I'm talking about socialism and Venezuela.
Take a listen to this.
Hi, I'm calling me miss.
And on top of all that, they killed over a
hundred million people know that because
yeah, it got cut off there.
Listen, I don't, I've made it abundantly clear
that I'm not a socialist and I've been extraordinarily
critical of the Venezuela regime regime under
Hugo Chavez and now Nicolas Maduro.
So criticized me for stuff I've said and interestingly
even after the Joe Rogan appearance last week
on which I said, my perspective here is not
a socialist perspective.
I'm a Social Democrat, which is a mixed economy.
It's a type of well-regulated capitalism.
I still got a ton of emails and tweets and
if you look at the comments on the Joe Rogan
interview, people saying, why did Joe Rogan
have this socialist on to tout socialism?
I'm not a socialist.
Okay, if you disagree with me on the policies,
I'm advocating, tell me why the policies are
wrong.
But to call them socialists and say that on
that basis they are wrong or bad.
I'm simply not a socialist and if I were a
socialist, I would be telling you if there
is any, there are many real serious critiques
that can be made of this program.
One that cannot be made is that I have been
anything but completely open and genuine with
the audience.
About what my views are.
I'm a Social Democrat, not a socialist.
If I were a socialist, I would tell you, if
I were a free market capitalist, I would tell
you, period, we've got a great bonus show
planned for you today.
We have some, uh, new things going on behind
the scenes at the show, which I will tell
you about.
Former red sox player, David Ortiz has been
shot and hospitalized in the Dominican Republic.
A very strange story, uh, and very sad.
And the Boston mayor is saying that the city
cannot stop the straight pride parade over
the values that it espouses.
We will talk about all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show.
Get instant access takes under a minute to
get instant access to the bonus show as a
member@davidpakmandotcomslashmembershiporasapatronatpatriondotcomslashdavidthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com